バンケ
ラジオ俺の名前は天才小学生そしてこいつ
が最強の母親きこ久しぶりにマクドナルド
を購入し
たやったやっ
た
バガいき
[音楽]
ます俺の大好きな
バガちゃんジャンクフードは体に悪いから
あなたはヘルシーな野菜をなさい
これ雑だくそあそうだ俺がハンバーガーを
開けばここのきなくハンバーガーを食べ
られるかもしれない子供が店なんて作れる
わけないでしょ俺ハンバーガ屋さんに
なる屋根のなるの転ですいらっしゃい
ませお可愛らしくていい
ね制服を可愛くしたおかげでアルバイトに
女の子が集まった看板娘だ
ぶっちゃけ時給も安いし店長子供だし微妙
だよ
ねこれ制服ですか
かわいい働くは働かせてくださいはい
頑張ろう
ねどうぞ目玉商品揚げバーガーです
うおいしいハンバーガーという美味しさの
塊をあげたらおいしいに決まってるんだキ
はこだよ
[音楽]
絶対俺が作ったCMで順調に子供たちが
集まってきてるよろしくお願い願いします
じゃ感情思いっきり出してね子供たちに
突き刺されるやつ
よいアクションラッキースラやすだよ喋っ
た僕天才ですからまた喋っ
たあお母さん殴ったね暴行剤で訴えるよ
やラッキーセットにやすレゴ
アイム
ジーニアスどうぞラッキーセット
です先生そんなに怒ると教育委員会に
訴えるよ
レトよしいいぞ食べ物だけでなく
マスコットキャラも置いて子供たちが
楽しめるようにするドナルドだよ
ランランルー
ゆとはい何ポテトあげるからバイトして
くれないえ
やるはいえポテト1本もくれんの
ありがとうこれクねわかりました
ポテテランランルーランランルって何
ドナルドは嬉しくなるとついやっちゃうん
だみんなも一緒にランランルー
イエ本日は話題のハンバーガ屋さんに来て
います
強烈がすごいですね早速入ってみますそう
大教のこのお店とあるユニークなメニュー
があるんだとか人気のうまい棒バーガーと
こちらのスマイル円いただけますか
もちろん
です小学生のスマイル
きお待たせしました棒バーガーですの神
さん贅沢に棒3もチーズまで乗っけてお
値段安すぎる
2500円思いやり価格早速いただき
ます
うチーズの濃厚さとうい棒の濃い味が
[音楽]
美味しいけんおこれ
欲しいやってんじゃん
さらにニュースで食べたくなった人たちの
ためにドローンを使って配達の人兵を削減
する
[音楽]
[拍手]
行け
すげえありがとうございますありがとう
ございますこのハンバーガーおいしい
ね
おありがとうありがとうございまし
ありがとうございまし
たです
からありがとうございまし
た平見語はハンバーガー食べよう
たお金も稼げてハンバーガーも食べるて
最高
だあれドナルドも食べないの
ドナルドドナルドは嬉しくなるとついやっ
ちゃうんだお母さん何してんだよ
ハンバーガー屋はお母さんが引き継ぐわは
わそもそも子供がお店やったりしたら法律
違反なんだから
ねキーコナルドリニューアルオープン
で2人
はいらっしゃいませあマッチョだわ
マッチョで人を引きつけるのよそれに
仕込んでいたCMもある
わ刺激的なCMにするわよはいはい感情
思い出し
なさいアンハッピー
ス頭勝ちわらよ喋っ
たロってあげましょうかしらまた喋った
体を引き裂いてメチにしてあげましょう
かしらしっ
たアンハッピーセットにキコ人形
アイムスお待たせしましたアンハッピー
セット
ですて夢に出てやる
ぞ何これ気持ち悪いはやめてちょだい
[音楽]
ハンバーガー美味しいもの組み合わせたら
美味しいに決まってる
でしょうおしましたきこのやみつけ
ハンバーガー
[音楽]
ですまずいこれ腐ってるんじゃない
のあれなんかお店変わったのかなま頼んで
いかさ無料配達行くわよはい
[音楽]
[拍手]
ます
よこのハーガーとポテトとゴーラ
ちだえっとプロテインがつでしたっけ
あんたこんなのも覚えられないのあんた
筋肉だけじゃないのこの
ノキマあ
あまっかない
おいちスマイルくださいはいはいはい
スマイルね美人キコのゼイスマイルね
[音楽]
え
あこんなの食べられないわよこれおかしい
じゃないのこんなハンマーが食べれないよ
この脳筋がスタフなんて何なのよこのお店
まずいぞまずいぞえなよ
はい
はいさお金待ってなさいお金払お金でなん
でもうやめそでやめんのあだちょっと待
され
[音楽]
よシクシクシクシク一生懸命作ったのに誰
も私のハンバーガー食べてくれないわ
シシおがめきこだなお前を逮捕するあ
ふざけじゃないわよそんなの知らないわよ
食べられないものを提供した食品衛生法
違反店を働かせた労働基準法犯ドローを無
許可で飛ばした交通法犯により大砲上がれ
ている細きこ
大砲行くぞめだほら来い
いい
おい面会
だお母さんやねちゃんお母さんごめんね僕
のせいでお母さんが捕まっちゃっていいの
よ私が悪かったわ普段からめちゃくちゃし
て本当にダメな親ねお母さん早く出てきて
よお母さんがいないと生きていけないよ
ごめんねやね
[音楽]
ちゃうごめん
ね間終了
だ
おおさ
[音楽]
な行動は改めなきゃね本当にダメだったわ
お母さんがいないと生きていけない
よ私がいないときっと屋根ちゃんダメに
なっ
[音楽]
ちゃうおい逃げた
ぞ待てこの野郎待ちやがれこの野郎待て
待て待て待て
待てやねちゃんのためな
[音楽]
わあやね
ちゃんてかさ屋根助ってお母さんいなくて
悲しくないの
いや最高だよあいつがいなくて生生してる
よあいつ毎回俺の手柄奪うからむかつくん
だよ警察にちくって正解だってよ
あそもそも子供がお店やったりしたら法律
違反なんだからね確かに法律違反だよな
お前ら来いはい
[拍手]
僕僕は無理に母親に働かされました完全に
労働人ホです神きこ無許可でドローンを
街中に飛ばしていまし
た腐ったご飯を提供していたので食品衛
違反です今すぐ捕まえてください細きこ
大砲ごめんねやね
ちゃうごめん
ねあいつまかからごめんとか言ってた
ああやねちゃんこれハンバーガーよお
お母さんまいっ
かいいないいおいしい
これ
ああこれが本当のスバがよ
やりすぎちゃったかしら
あべちゃちゃチャンネル登録チャンネル
登録チャンネル登録よろしくチャンネル
登録チャンネル登録チャンネル登録
よろしく最初はチャンネル登録チャンネル
登録チャンネル
登録DET